ABCs of AI L is for llms llm stands for
large language Model A type of
artificial intelligence that has the
ability to produce human-like responses
to natural language inputs llms use deep
learning techniques to process and
generate text and are trained on massive
data sets of code and text this allows
them to perform a wide variety of
natural language processing tasks like
summarizing text generating text
answering questions detecting plagiarism
categorizing text and so much more in
fact Google uses llms in the background
to improve many of our products such as
sentence Auto completion in Gmail
expanding Google translate capabilities
better understanding queries in Google
search and of course Bard an llm-powered
chatbot experiment that allows people to
collaborate directly with generative AI
don't forget to subscribe so you can
tune in to the next episode of
[Music]